welcome back in the last video I just
you know at the end of the video like I
always do an attempt to confuse you I
told you that if I had two vectors and
let me just make up some new ones just
so I can draw them visually you know in
a second or two let's call the first
vector a let me do a different color
this toothpaste color is getting
monotonous let me do something that
looks relaxing so let's call a first
vector a and I don't know let's say it's
let me put some make it interesting lets
me say it's -3 times the unit vector I
plus 2 times the unit vector J and then
I have vector B and that is equal to I
don't know let's say it's 2 I 2 times
the unit vector I plus I don't know let
me say 4 times the unit vector J in the
last video I said well the whole reason
why this unit vector notation is even
well one of the reasons what we'll see
that there are many reasons why it's
useful but one of the really cool things
about it is before when we added vectors
we would put them head to tails and then
draw it visually and then we'd have this
new vector and we really had no way of
expressing it without drawing it but
when we write things as multiples of the
unit vectors we don't have to draw it
and it's actually very easy to add
vectors and how do we do it we just add
the X components and we add the Y
components so we said that these these
two vectors a plus B these little weird
arrows on top that's just saying that
those are vectors did that equals oh
this should be an equal sign equals not
not equals that's equals so it's minus 3
plus 2i and I'm going to arbitrary
switch colors because it's getting
monotonous plus 2 plus 4j we just added
the X components or the multiples of I
and we added the Y components or just
the multiples of J right because I was
the unit vector in the X direction and J
was unit vector in the Y direction and
we get what's minus 3 plus 2 that's
minus 1 so we get minus 1 I or that
could just be minus I but I'll write the
1 just because we're just getting warmed
up with unit vector so minus 1 I
+6 J and when I did that you might say
well Sal you know I can't just take your
word for it because you you've seen kind
of a you know not not someone who should
should be believed blindly so and I
think that's a valid opinion to have so
I will show you that this works by doing
by adding the vectors visually so let's
let's draw it and I think this will give
you a little better sense of of unit
vectors generally let me draw the axes
the axes so that's my X that's my y-axis
and let me draw my x-axis to make sure I
have enough space to draw the unit
vectors that we've drawn under draw the
vectors that we've drawn so that's just
to show you that the axes go on forever
I have to draw that arrow alright so
let's see I go so let's say this is 1 2
3 this is 1 2 3 4 I draw 1 2 3 4 5 6 I
think we should be able to now add them
I didn't have to waste all this space
down here so let's just first draw the
vectors minus 3i plus 2j so minus 3i so
minus 3i just this this right here is
going to be a vector that looks
something like this so it'll go it's
just minus 3 times the X vector so it'll
go to the left
right because I is the pause is 1 in the
positive direction so if we if we put a
negative there it flips it over let me
do it in a different color so this is
minus 3i and then plus 2j so plus 2j
looks like this alright this is plus 2j
and if we were add those two vectors
visually we can put them head to tails
and the way we could do that we could
either shift this vector up like this
and draw it up here we could shift this
vector and put its tail to this vectors
head but either way so let's shift the
one up so if we shift it up like that
now remember we're just doing the head
to tails visual addition method of
vectors so I just put this tail to this
head and what do we get
so vector a will look like this and I'm
going to do it in the same color as
vector a just so because I have a
feeling that this diagram might get
complicated
well if I wanted to use the line tool it
undo into the line tool okay so this is
vector a that's what vector a it looks
like and so we worked backwards I gave
you the X component and the y component
and then I added them together by doing
the head to tails method and so this is
what vector a would look like and
instead of drawing it a very easy
representation is exactly what we did up
here the unit vector notation and what's
a vector B look like so it's two I'm
going to do a completely different color
it's 2i so it's this vector two times
the unit vector I that's this plus four
J 4 J 1 2 3 4 so it looks like this and
if let's take this one and shift it over
to the left so we can put its tail to
this vectors head so would we look like
this so vector B will look and I'll do
it in red and I'll use the line tool
vector B looks like this all right I
just put its components head to tails
and that's how I got vector B and if I
were to add them visually I would do it
the same way that I added its components
I would put the tail of one vector to
the head of the other and see get the
resulting vector so we can do it either
way let's shift this a vector let's
shift it in this direction and put it
because remember vectors we're just
giving a magnitude in a direction we're
not telling you we're not necessarily
giving a starting point so you can shift
them you just can't change their
orientation or the magnitude and that's
actually how you add them you've shift
them and put them head to tails that's
when you add them visually so let's put
that a vector let's put it up here so if
we have the a vector it looks something
like this and I know my the a vector
we'll look something like this and I
want it to work out right some so the a
vector something like that and remember
all I did is I took the same vector and
I just shifted it so that it can start
at the head so its tail can start at the
head of the B vector right so I just
shifted the a vector so this is still
the a vector by moving a vector around
you haven't changed the vector
I would only change the vector if I
scaled it if I made it bigger or smaller
if I if I change this to orientation and
so visually this is B this is a so if I
add a to be the resulting vector going
head to tails I'll do it in in let me
see elders in the screen color would
look like this
it would look like that right so here we
took all this trouble and I had to draw
these straight lines to visually add
these two vectors this green vector is a
plus B let's see if this green vector is
the same thing that we got that we got
here let's see if it's the same thing as
this so we got negative one times I so
negative one is like here and then we
have six j6j let me do it in another
color
6j would look like this 6j looks like
that you put them heads to tails and it
would get would be something like this
and that is the green vector and
actually just so you know I know it
didn't line up perfectly and that's
because I'm not drawing neatly but these
two points should actually be here if I
were to have drawn this better but I
know this was very confusing I had all
these colors but the whole point of it
is I wanted you to show that you know
you could visually draw vectors and then
have you know shift them around and then
put them heads to tails and then get the
resulting vector that's one way to add
vectors and there's still real no way to
end the analytically represented it or
you could just write any vector as it's
x and y-components
and then the sum of the vectors is just
going to be the sum of the x's and then
the sum of the Y's and that's a much
cleaner and a much easier and much less
prone to error way of adding or
subtracting really two vectors so
hopefully that was convincing that this
that a plus G
a plus B really is this vector if it
wasn't I'm sorry
and I hope I didn't confuse you more but
now that we have this out of the way and
hopefully you're convinced that unit
vector notation is useful we can move on
and maybe try to do some of our old
projectile motion problems using this
notation and maybe it'll let us to do a
little bit extra stuff with it see you
soon